[APPLAUSE]
>> OK.
I am going to put figment up here since I
am too short for the podium anyway.
Hi, everyone.
I am here today to talk you on a journey into
imagination.
I think my slides just cut out, though.
Can you confirm that?
There we go.
I am going to tell you a little about me.
I am Rachel White and I am the developer experience
lead at American Express which means it is
my job to help improve the developer experience
of learning and interacting with our APIs
internally.
Helping to fix pipelines and make things easier
for our developers, whether you are an internal
employee, the one building those, or if you
are an external partner, wanting to implement
our stuff.
I am also on the community committee for node.js.
Things like evangelism, internationalization,
inclusive and there Node website.
I care a lot about the creative thought processes
especially whether it comes to programming.
-- when.
This is going to be a weird talk which is
nothing new for me.
This one is a little more cute than weird.
As a little bit of background, I am so excited
to use the sparkle transition.
I have never gotten to do that and felt like
this was the perfect excuse to finally get
to do it.
This is me.
I don't know how old I am.
Probably like under seven.
I don't understand children.
I have been to Disney over 50 times.
I grew up near Disney World and I have been
going since before I could talk.
I have old home videos of me as a baby and
my aunt is holding me and she is like Rachel
look at mickey and my foot is in my mouth
so...
The thing I really like about it is the immersive
experience you have in the park and kind of
escape from reality it provided.
It was really thrilling and exciting to me
and that probably correlates with my love
for tiki bars.
I just like not being in the regular world.
Whenever I couldn't go to the park for a few
years and I would visit again there would
always be something new to see.
I started thinking about the experiences that
I had as child that helped shape me to who
I am professionally and realize Disney is
a big part of it.
Yes, I love Disney world but I am going to
tell you about the park I love even more.
And that is Epcot.
I fell in love with Epcot the first moment
I can remember experiencing it which was in
the late '80s.
Epcot stands for the experimental prototype
community of tomorrow.
There is two major parts of the park.
The first one is the World Showcase and the
next one is Future world.
Epcot is dedicated to the celebration of human
achievement, mainly technological innovation
and international culture.
It is also often referred to as the world's
fair.
The world's showcase has 11 sections representing
different countries.
Most people know about the world showcase
because it is one of the places that everybody
over 21 goes to get drunk in the Disney parks.
Future World is a variety of pavilions that
explore innovative aspects and applications
including technology and science.
While I could go on forever about all of the
things I love about the park in general we
are going to focus on one major part and that
is the imagination pavilion which is my figment
is here and why I decided to match him.
The imagination pavilion has to deal with
imagination.
It was colorful and fun inside and encouraged
kids to be creative and adults.
Associated with the imagination pavilion is
the dream finder, the non-dragon, and figment
who is the dragon.
The best part about the imagination pavilion
was a section inside called image works.
It lasted from 1982-1988.
Where was born at the end of 1985 so I am
surprised that I can still remember some of
this.
There were things that you could interact
with.
Like these step tones where guests could create
music by stepping on the different light and
making different tones.
There was also this coloring book thing where
you had paint brushes and you could paint
the colors and it all filled it in with light.
There were giant touch pen tables.
You know, like those things you put your face
into and all the little metal pins.
It sounds gross when you think about all the
people touching it but it was really cool.
It was really fun and encouraged you to, like,
do things with technology but creatively.
Inside the imagination pavilion was a dark
ride which is what the rides in Disney that
are in the dark are called.
Who would have thought?
It was called journey into imagination and
the inspiration for this talk is where I got
the name from.
This one lasted from 1983-1999 and in the
ride the dream finder introduces himself and
says he uses the dream mobile to collect dreams
and ideas to create all sorts of new things.
So then he creates a figment of his imagination
and I wanted to show you some footage from
that ride I found from 1996 so you can experience
the same thing I got to as a child because
this ride has had two other iterations after
it and they are bad.
They are really bad.
So enjoy this video.
It is two minutes and 30 seconds.
Here we go.
[Playing video]
>> So one thing this video also shows is that
people have been taking bad videos since before
cellphones could except was really big and
on our shoulder.
THAFRT part -- after that part of the ride,
you go through and explore a bunch of creative
applications and they talk about science and
how scientists and astronauts and using your
creativity you can be whatever you want and
how creativeness can apply to anything.
It doesn't just have to be the arts.
I was like that is awesome.
The experiences I had as a kid with the imagination
pavilion.
There is me with their dream finder and figment.
I am sure it isn't the same one.
They look a little different.
That led me to do a lot of research on the
things I loved about the park.
So the blend of the education and the creative
learning.
I wanted to know more about how they did it.
I started reading more about the imagineers
and I found this quote from Disney.
We are always exploring and experimenting
and call it Imagineering.
Imagineers are responsible for building Disney
theme parks, resorts and cruise ships.
They do the rides but they also do the interior
of the restaurants to the menu design.
It is everything.
Everyone is an imagineer.
There is over 140 job titles including architectures,
engineers, show writers, graphic designers.
All these multi-disciplinary people are using
the same principles for when they create.
I read a few books and realized how perfect
this is for what we do every day.
I know not everyone likes Disney and that
is fine.
What I think is the most important thing is
how successful and adaptable their model for
creating is and that is something to learn
from.
Why apply this to software?
You are probably like OK, this is for a theme
park and how can I possibly utilize this?
From the time you in line they keep you captivated.
Wouldn't you want someone reading your documentation
or going through your demos to feel engaged?
You don't want to lose their attention in
the middle of the important things you are
telling them.
So basically all of the imagineers go by mickey's
10 commandments and they were created by Marty
similar and they were from his early learning
in his 56-year career at Disney.
I think they are extremely helpful for our
own processes.
We talk a lot about strategic thinking or
thinking more technical.
For each 10 commandments I will talk about
Disney's reason behind it and how I feel week
utilize that with our own users and code.
Number one know your audience, wear your guest
shoes, three is organize the flow of ideas,
four create a visual magnet, five communicate
with visual literacy, six; avoid overload.
Seven; tell one story at a time.
Eight; avoid contradictions and maintain identity.
Nine; for every ounce of treatment provide
a ton of treat and the easy one to adapt to
programming is keep it up and maintain it.
Let's jump in.
For the first one, know your audience.
How you communicate and what you communicate
is totally who you identify as your target
audience.
Disney started planning by going to other
amusement parks with his daughter and sitting
on a bench and observing what worked and what
didn't.
He didn't start his vision for the parks without
knowing who he was making it for.
For us as engineers it is also important to
know our audience.
More well-established projects, track metrics
and behavior of users but that is people who
are using a product already.
What can we do to plan before we even write
a piece of code?
If we have an idea for the end result, why
don't we take a look at similar projects or
projects you aspire to be like?
How do the users interact?
What could you do better?
This could be something like what languages
do they support or are we going to use npm
or Yarn?
Someone who does this fantastically, not someone,
a project that does this fantastically is
NodeBot.
The way they cater for every skill level makes
the process fun and engaging.
If you don't know what you are doing, it is
OK because they have documentation available
so you can find the pieces you need and piece
it together to get what you need to get done.
They are aware people using Nodebots are venturing
into the hardware for the first time and make
it easy to do that.
If you are more advance, they have a room
where you can chat and harass them to get
them to help you out -- not that I have ever
done that.
Number two is wear your guest shoes.
Walt insisted every designer had to go to
the park every week and stand in lines to
understand how the guests were experiencing
it.
When writing your documentation, give it to
somebody else to try.
See if it is written plainly enough and accessible
to all levels.
Appeal to more than just the senior programmer.
The more open you are to all levels of skills
enables more adoption for your project.
More people talk about it and encourage more
to use it.
Earlier on in my career, I dealt with undocumented
code basis and documents that were too hard
for me to use because there wasn't a level
of thought and care put into it for the user.
I have told myself I make sure anything I
have my hand in making won't treat people
the same since then.
So here is an example of that.
This is Webpack.
A poor example of this, in my opinion, is
what Webpack has on their landing page.
It is a super important bundler a ton of people
use but I can't tell you the amount of times
I have heard programmers say I don't get it
or it is too hard.
It is that simple as really not a great thing
to say.
I gave a quick version of this talk at Brooklyn
JS as in I spoke as quickly as I could to
fit it in 10 minutes and I went over.
At the end of it, Jen came up to me and said
Rachel stop being negative and reach out to
Sean Larkin and suggest to change it because
that would be a better case study than coming
up here saying Webpack is bad.
I messaged him and he was pumped and totally
chill about it.
He agreed with me.
They opened up a poll request and are workshopping
a better title for that section.
Don't be afraid to reach out to maintainers
with suggestions for better language in the
project or suggestions for any kind of improvements.
You are helping them.
The next one is organize the flow of people
and ideas.
So, the important part of this is good stories
and experiences have logic and sequence that
pay off for the time and effort that the users
put in.
Put this care into your documentation.
Don't just give code samples and call it a
day.
Craft an experience for the users.
Give them a backstory on what you are trying
to achieve with the creation.
Give them all the instructions and tools you
need before getting to the code.
Include a section with a link to commonly
encountered errors or issues that people have.
Each step along the way will step them up
for success.
A company that does this fantastically is
Twilio.
When you sign up for their services, during
the sign-up process they ask you what language
is your primary language and when you are
done with the sign-up, the things you are
looking up are already there in the language
you are looking for so you don't have to go
digging for it and that is great.
The next one is create a visual magnet.
Disney has visual magnets throughout the park
and they draw you in from a distance to a
specific part.
The rocket ship in tomorrow land and space
and earth in Epcot serve as a visual line
but a point of reference for park goers so
you can coordinate meet up plans and everybody
knows what you are talking about.
In programming one way you can do this is
by being unique with your demos.
Create something exciting for people to build
while learning how to use your code.
It will definitely stick out more than giving
them a generic hello world or a to-do list.
Somebody that does this fantastically is Wes
Boss.
The React for beginners course you build a
fun sea food inventory page.
It is fun, helps explain props and states
and it is one of my favorite resources to
use whenever I need to go back and refresh
React stuff which is all the time because
I have a terrible memory.
I can associate the things I learned with
each step of the tutorial which is memorable
and important.
The next one is communicate with visual literacy.
Imagineer use a ton of non-verbal ways to
communicate.
Make sure you take advantage of the non-verbal
tools you have at your command.
How is your documentation?
Is it all sample code?
What could you do in order to improve the
user's experience?
So many people coming into programming are
coming from non-traditional computer science
backgrounds or are changing their jobs later
in life coming in as visual learners.
They need diagrams, drawings and cartoons
to grasp concepts that might be new to them
so use them.
And somebody who does this great is Lynn Clark.
Her code cartoons are helpful and explain
a lot of concepts visually and it helps it
make sense versus reading an article about
Redux which who wants to do that?
The next is avoid overload.
When imagineers take on a new project the
second task is to reduce everything to what
is important.
You want a lot of information in your documentation
but you need structure it well.
Don't have one long page going to all the
information surrounding the API.
Break it up into different parts.
One section to get started, another for API
reference and another for code snip want -- snippets.
Stripe does this well.
You know where you need to go exactly where
you need to go.
They don't overload you with too much information
at the get-go.
The next one is tell one story at a time.
Good stories are clear, logical and consistent.
Disney invented the story board in the 1930s
which I didn't know about before I started
the research.
The whole point is to create a story line
that holds together from end to end.
It is to create a story they can review with
anyone even if they are not involved in the
process and they will be able to understand
it.
Story board your documentation as well.
Think of where you want the user to start
out and at the end what knowledge you want
them to come out that they didn't have at
the beginning.
If it is just an API reference that is one
thing.
For something more technically written come
up with a scenario and tell it that way.
Case studies and user stories are also a fantastic
thing to use for this.
Was that a double slide?
Sorry about that.
Wait.
Storyboard.
That was double.
OK.
Sorry about that.
The next one is tell one story at a time which
I should have taken for this talk because
I just got confused.
Wait, no, I see what is happening.
That went double.
OK.
Here we go.
Keynote.
Listen, I worked on a Window machine for the
last year and a half and I am getting used
to this again.
OK.
Here we go.
Somebody that does this really well is D3.
While not being the, like, cleanest of the
presentation of examples they have a whole
section of real-world implementations of D3
being used which is helpful.
A lot of libraries don't take advantage of
this.
It really is the easiest way to show someone
implementations they can take and build off
to get started.
A working example of code is better than snippets
they can just piece together sometimes.
The next one is avoid contradictions.
The design details of Disney is friendly.
Nothing is screaming out for attention.
The graphics are equal in representation.
You know where you are.
The details make for a pleasant experience.
So, leave out the details of wants and things
that didn't work out in your documentation.
Keep only the positive messages.
Sometimes people explain hardships they explain
while making something or something they didn't
get to.
Leave it out.
Don't include negativity unless it is something
you learned from and there is a lesson.
No TO -- no to dos in read me.
Disney educates but they don't tell you they
are doing so.
They let you discover and learn while being
surrounded by fun and excitement.
I gave a talk last year at JSConf EU about
learning how to program in sites before stack
overflow and hacker news where they gamified
knowledge sharing and how much more fun it
was then.
Try to go back to the feeling you had when
you were first learning to code and try to
add that magic and fun into your project.
Somebody who does this perfectly is sailor
HG.
Amy makes these super informative scenes about
computer science through creative projects.
They are really engaging and keep you interested.
And the last, but probably the most important,
commandment is keep it up, maintain it.
Disney is spotless and since it is kept so
clean the guests inherently keep it clean.
Not wanting to contribute trash to an otherwise
nice-looking area.
You are wanting to find the nearest trash
can without thinking about it.
The rides are well maintained and that takes
a ton of effort.
If everything wasn't functioning the way it
intended it would not be the same Disney experience.
The same principles go for code.
Maintain it, pay attention to the users, don't
ignore poll requests.
I know that is hard for a big project but
try to keep it as the basis for everyone involved
to check-in and see if there is people in
there wanting to help.
So, yeah, check these things.
I am not saying what project this is for.
It is big.
Anyway... so basically what I am trying to
say is a creative thinking process is beneficial
to technical material.
It allows us to reach more people than it
would if we stick to dry documentation with
a lot of technical jargon.
Putting care into tracking users will make
all potential projects better in the long
run.
This book, one little spark, is the inspiration
for my talk.
It is really interesting if you want to check
it out.
If you like what I had to say today or want
to yell at me, I don't know, you can find
me a couple places I am ohhoe on Twitter and
I have been streaming content on Twitter every
Monday and Friday at 4:00 p.m. pacific.
I started with freecodecamp starting at the
way at HTML and I will make my way all the
way to info stack and I am just streaming
to try and show other developers that vulnerability
is OK.
I had a test go wrong trying to write a horizontal
rule tag.
I was like there is no way something is wrong
and I had to search freecodecamp test broken
and I was right and I was like I knew the
was right.
I am also going to be creating fun videos
on YouTube of programming and hardware for
non-programmers.
I am calling both of these what the help because
it is cute.
I am on Drip which is kick starters Patreon
platform.
This was journey into imagination.
I am Rachel White.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]